si sony leur chalet jean paul gaultier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marchal genton bonsoir 2100 j'en passe
alors tony vous êtes une enfant de la
balle
puisque vous êtes la fille de bill
marchal acteur réalisateur américain le
mari de mme michèle morgan à une époque
est donc le grand père de la fameuse
sarah marshall et oui deux parentes un
petit peu que ça marche assez ma nièce
c'est votre voix là mais je la connais
très peu mais on s'est vus
il ya assez longtemps avant qu'elle
épouse j'ai oublié son nom avec son
alexandre anthony voilà il faudra
beaucoup tous les deux mais il paraît
dans vos yeux avec la fille donc de bill
marshall et de micheline presle absents
évidemment cette grande actrice course
algérie qu on adore tous mes fils prenne
voilà et quand vous étiez enfant vous
dormiez dans une chambre qui jouxtait la
salle de projection du studio des
ursulines
alors quand il était tout petit vous
entendiez leçon et puis ensuite c'est
devenu copine avec l'ouvreuse et puis
elle vous laisser rentrer dans la salle
du studio des ursulines
comme ça vous avez vu très jeunes des
films de godard de bergman les einstein
enfin vraiment vous avez une formation
très précoce j'avais la cabine du
projectionniste était à peu près on
était séparés par une cour de trois
mètres et donc l'été particulièrement il
aller fumer une clope sur le l'escalier
en métal et donc il ouvrait la porte de
la cabine et j'ai donc j'ai connu les
films en entier par le son je connais
alexandre nevsky pratiquement
phonétiquement etc voilà alors vous avez
fait plein de films vous à votre tour
ensuite le plus connu disons c'est vénus
beauté institut qui a été nominé sept
fois aux césar qui avait décroché quatre
césar du meilleur film du meilleur
scénario de la meilleure réalisatrice et
meilleur espoir féminin pour la fameuse
audrey tautou route qui depuis a fait
qu'est-ce que la flore si elle est têtue
audrey tautou
non peut-être que tu la connais mieux
sous le nom de
amélie catherine qu'il dit amélie
poulain de labeur et votre dernier film
j'étais france boutiques dont judith
godrèche c'est venu parler ici cette île
à voir demain jusqu'à demain après midi
sur france 5
absolument absolument je ne sais pas un
match de foot non non à 15h30 sur france
5 il ya un documentaire de tonie
marshall sur jean paul gaultier voilà
alors au début quand on vous a dit de
faire un documentaire vous vous êtes dit
oui l'a jamais fait le documentaire
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
et puis
vous pareil vous dites oh là là je vais
pas avoir une équipe sur le dos pendant
cinq mois donc au départ c'était pas
c'était pas évident savait pas encore
que celle est tonie marshall
quand j'ai su que c'était elle et ce qui
nous réunit c'est un film un film sur la
mode un film des années 50 un film de
jacques becker qui s'appelle falbala
dont l'héroïne est votre maman micheline
presle et il se trouve que micheline
presle vous vous l'adorez dervout
l'avait habillée pour le propos les
césar on voit ça la fin du documentaire
d'ailleurs c'est oui tout à fait puisque
bon moi je suis un enfant de la télé on
va dire donc gg je regardais la télé
tuant tout gamin et je me souviens qu'à
un moment j'avais vu l'émission des
folies bergères sur les folies bergères
dont je voulais à billets je vais faire
des costumes pour les folies bergères ça
a commencé comme ça et puis après j'ai
vu falbala et là ça a été le coup de
foudre totale je dis non c'est la mode
ça je vous devais avoir j'ai pas 12 ans
10 12 ans et c'est quand même
probablement le seul film qui raconte le
processus d'une collection de haute
couture du début jusqu'à la fin se dire
qu'après ça c'était la vérité c'était ma
bible en quelques sortes
voilà un certain jacques becker très
beau film alors le documentaire
s'appelle les falbalas de jean paul
gaultier est pas pour rien donc vous
parler de votre vie professionnelle et
puis de votre vie privée alors sur le
plan professionnel
on apprend que vous dessinez deux
collections par an dont vous êtes
toujours dans l'urgence quoi c'est ouais
ouais c'est un petit peu c'est ça le
rythme de la mode c'est c'est assez
étonnant
en plus on peut faire quelquefois des
collections qui sont plusieurs saisons
en même temps fin là je suis à la fois
sur l'été et l'hiver enfin alors on
découvre voici dans ce documentaire vous
laisser appeler monsieur comme coco
chanel se faisait appeler mademoiselle
jusqu'à présent budget jean paul houée
bon d'abord parce qu'on n'était pas
nombreux et puis j'ai commencé par du
affaires du prêt-à-porter
on s'était pas la même façon là même le
même vocabulaire on va dire que dans la
couture où j'ai commencé et en assistant
mais là comme j'ai pris certaines
personnes certaines comment met-on la
première d'atelier qui venait de la
couture elle avait l'habitude de dire
monsieur parce qu'elle travaillait avec
monsieur givenchy donc ça a été monsieur
donc je me suis retrouvée d'un seul coup
paf avec monsieur ouais ça va un peu
chanel qua non sauf que c'était
mademoiselle donc à elle m'a pas dit
mademoiselle sera peut-être un peu plus
étonné c'est
mademoiselle vous parlez de votre vie
privée aussi d'une façon assez franche
je trouve un bon jeu pourra sinon c'est
vrai c'était c'est ouais ouais je me
casse le documentaire vous avez évité
une psychanalyse sûrement mais oui c'est
ça ce que je disais en fin de compte
j'ai merci thani c'est tout à fait ça
quel boulot quand même commis alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez que vous
l'avez eue là pendant cinq mois c'est
absolument étonnant c'est à dire que
je crois qu'il parle il a un espèce de
on va dire qu un espèce de petit
cimetière de bouts de tissus de plumes
jaillissantes yagg d'état trucs comme ça
elle arriva derrière il tripote des tas
de morceaux comme ça il tripote
énormément il a absolument besoin de ça
il a pas de dessin il a vaguement des
trucs collé au mur qui regarde pas
souvent
et puis tripote il tripote il tripote
s'il ya des tonnelles et qui après il
commence à avoir une toile
et puis voilà c'est il ya des choses on
veut on le voit dans le documentaire il
ya des moments où ça rate complètement
où il sépare etc
et puis tout d'un coup ça vient et là
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que on
voit qu est ce que c'est qu'un moment où
nul parce que jean-paul il ne crée le
vêtement que par la parole il n'arrête
pas de parler ou alors il dit tout en
tout le temps alors là le titre on t'a
fait si ça fait ça puis au bout d'un
moment ils arrêtent de dire le tissu il
commence à dire alors là je vais avoir
ça un peu plus serré dit dont l'âge de
cloques et puis alors là je god
donc je vais remonter alors il faut il
faut je ne suis pas doubler et il se met
absolument la place du vêtement et à
partir de là le discours structure alors
qu'avant je viens de vêtements mais il
devient le vêtement et c'est très sympa
et ça est un peu après il perfectionne
les cinglés quoi loyen cintrée
[Musique]